don't ask about who this person was
referenced in the what's that message
the big guy don't ask don't tell joining
me now is Tristan Levitt he's the IRS
whistleblower Gary shapley's attorney
you saw him sitting behind the
whistleblowers today it was a long day
Tristan I know you just wrapped up now
this was all said under oath criminal
threat of of line to Congress that's a
big big No-No
um so what would you what would any
whistleblower at this point given what's
happened gain
from exaggerating or telling untruths
before Congress given everything that
we've seen happen to any whistleblower
who doesn't happen to be you know trying
to go after Trump absolutely nothing and
the the crazy thing for Gary
particularly is again he's the head of
this Elite unit 12 agents report to him
from around the country he's done credit
Swiss and these other major things he
has zero reason to try and risk his
career other than the truth and his
conscience so what one Democrat
Congressman said about your client
what they're basically saying is David
Weiss is a liar well you know what look
David Weiss is going to have to defend
themselves but I think we would find it
very odd that these are the guys telling
the truth and David Weiss someone who
had to go through the U.S Senate somehow
I'm not telling the truth as a processor
ooh the U.S Senate that's because they
never get it wrong your response I think
he represented himself very well today I
think the American public could see for
themselves exactly who Gary and Jose
Ziegler were and I think it was
impressive what would to you was the
most important part of today I mean one
moment
for them to talk about
the key imperative to them that their
goal is not to take any particular uh
plea deal or anything else it's just
that they believe in Equal justice under
the law they just they're Americans who
care about the system that's absolutely
right that's why well rokana tried to
smear your clients today uh their
credibility watch
is it true that you have often disagreed
your recommendations have often been
disregarded before when it comes to
charging dis decisions is that true I I
don't think disregard is accurate
representative they have been people in
your own IRS have disagreed with your
decisions often before is that accurate
that's not accurate Tristan weren't
those individuals only acting in an
advisory capacity absolutely and what
Gary didn't didn't jump out to point out
is it's not just his team everyone is
all these International investigations
CT Council disagrees with that's why
they are as he said not respected by
prosecutors so they're the ones who have
the credibility problem the people who
are disagreeing with the whistleblowers
yeah and I think it's important also
this is really down in the weeds but to
understand their role which is just they
want to highlight these could be
difficult prosecutions anytime you're
dealing internationally of course they
could be so that's all that they're
saying is that it's hard to go after
those would a bureaucrat ever not want
to work no all right Tristan great to
see you thank you so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else